>>> THIS IS "DON LEMON TONIGHT."
WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS ON THE
CHAOS IN WASHINGTON NOW.
DEMOCRATS ARE BATTLING THEIR OWN
IN A DESPERATE ATTEMPT TO PUSH
JOE BIDEN'S AGENDA ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE.
SOURCES TELLING CNN THE
PRESIDENT IS EXPECTED TO ATTEND
A HOUSE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
MEETING ON CAPITOL HILL BRIGHT
AND EARLY TOMORROW MORNING 9:00
A.M. DELAYING THE DEPARTURE FOR
EUROPE BY A FEW HOURS TO CONVIPS
PROGRESSIVES TO VOTE FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL TOMORROW.
THAT AS A LOT OF DEMOCRATS ARE
FURIOUS TONIGHT PAID FAMILY AND
MEDICAL LEAVE IS NOW LIKELY TO
END UP ON THE SCRAP HEAT OUT.
ALONG WITH THROUGH TUITION FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, MARGINAL TAX
RATE INCREASES AND THE CLEAN
ENERGY PROGRAM.
JOE MANSION DOESN'T THINK THE
PAID LEAVE POLICY SHOULD BE IN
THE BILL AT ALL.
ONE DEMOCRATIC SENATOR TELLING
CNN QUOTE PEOPLE ARE PISSED HE
WANTS TO TAKE OUT PAID FAMILY
LEAVE.
>> THE PROBLEM IS WITH THE
MEMBERS HERE ALTHOUGH THEY'RE
VERY FEW IN NUMBER, THERE ARE A
SIGNIFICANT MINORITY THINK THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO DETERMINE WHAT
THE REST OF THE CONGRESS SHOULD
BE DOING.
THE MINORITY SHOULD NOT BE
DICTATING TO THE MAJORITY.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S INITIAL
12-WEEK FAMILY LEAVE PROPOSAL
WAS SCALED BACK TO FOUR WEEKS IN
AN EFFORT TO GET MANSION SUPPORT
BUT THAT DIDN'T WORK.
NEITHER APPARENTLY HAS AN EFFORT
BY SENATOR CHRISTIAN GILLIBRAND
TO FIND A COMPROMISE WITH
MANSION THAT SAYS TONIGHT QUOTE,
I JUST CAN'T DO IT.
THE QUESTION IS CAN DEMOCRATS
GET OUT OF THEIR OWN WAY AND
MAKE A DEAL WITH JUST HOURS TO
GO UNTIL THE PRESIDENT'S TRIP?
WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT ON
THE INVESTIGATION OF THE
SHOOTING ON THE SET OF ALEC
BALDWIN'S MOVIE "RUST" THAT
KILLED CINEMATOGRAPHER HELD LEAN
-- HALYNA HUTCHINS AND INJURED
JOEL SOUZA.
THE DIRECTOR SAYING THIS.
>> THERE ARE SAFETY PROTOCOLS
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE FOLLOWED
BID EVERYONE IN THE INDUSTRY AND
THAT DID NOT HAPPEN IN THIS CASE
ON MULTIPLE LEVELS.
>> THERE IS A NEW SEARCH WARRANT
AFFIDAVIT WITH A SHOCKING
REVELATION.
THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR DAVID
HALLS FAILED TO FULLY CHECK THE
GUN THAT FIRED THE FATAL SHOT
BEFORE HE HANDED IT TO ALEC
BALDWIN, AGAIN, ACCORDING TO THE
AFFIDAVIT.
THE AFFORD REVEALING 24-YEAR-OLD
HANNA REED GUTIERREZ ONLY ON HER
SECOND MOVIE, NO LIVE AMMO IS
EVER KEPT ON THE SET BUT THAT'S
NOT WHAT THE SHERIFF SAYS.
IN A PRESS CONFERENCE TODAY HE
SAYS THE GUN DISCHARGED BY ALEC
BALDWIN FIRED A SUSPECTED LIVE
ROUND.
>> I THINK THE FACTS ARE CLEAR.
A WEAPON WAS HANDED TO MR.
BALDWIN.
THE WEAPON IS FUNCTIONAL AND
FIRED A LIVE ROUND KILLING MS.
HUTCHINS AND INJURING MR. SOUZA.
>> HE SAID INVESTIGATORS
RECOVERED WHAT THEY BELIEVE TO
BE ADDITIONAL LIVE ROUNDS ON THE
SET.
>> THE ACTUAL LED PROJECTILE
THAT WAS FIRED HAS BEEN
RECOVERED FROM THE SHOULDER OF
MR. SOUZA.
WE REGARD THIS SPECIFIC SPENT
CASING AND RECOVERED PROJECTILE
TO BE THE LIVE ROUND THAT WAS
FIRED FROM THE REVOLVER BY MR.
BALDWIN.
WE HAVE RECOVERED WHAT WE
BELIEVE TO BE POSSIBLE
ADDITIONAL LIVE ROUNDS ON SET.
>> SO MANY QUESTIONS RAISED
DURING THIS PRESS CONFERENCE,
AND IN THIS CASE, I DON'T KNOW.
IT MAY TURN ON THE ANSWERS.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WHY WAS THERE SO MUCH
AMMUNITION, LIVE AMMUNITION ON A
MOVIE SET?
HOW MANY LIVE ROUNDS WERE THERE?
AND WAS THERE A LACK OF
SERIOUSNESS ABOUT SAFETY ON THIS
PARTICULAR SET?
THERE IS A LOT TO BE ANSWERED.
THERE IS A LOT OF BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT.
WE WANT TO GET TO THE NEWS
HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON D.C.
FIRST ON CAPITOL HILL.
I WANT TO BRING IN JESSICA DEAN
AND WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
ARLET SIGNS.
GOOD EVENING TO BOTH OF YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING.
HERE WE GO.
IT GETTING DOWN TO THE WIRE.
THERE IS SO MUCH MOVEMENT ON
THIS SPENDING BILL TONIGHT.
SEEMS LIKE NEGOTIATIONS ARE
CHANGING BY THE MINUTE.
WHERE DO THINGS STAND NOW?
>> THEY ARE.
IT WAS A WHIRL WIND OF ACTIVITY
TODAY AND TOMORROW.
TO GIVE YOU THE HEADLINES HERE.
THEY ARE STILL SEARCHING FOR A
TOP LINE NUMBER HOW MUCH THIS
WILL ULTIMATELY COST THEM AND
ALSO, EXACTLY HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO PAY FOR THAT.
THE REVENUE.
HOW WILL THEY CREATE THE MONEY
TO PAY FOR THIS AND THE ISSUES,
THE SEPARATE PROVISIONS GOING
INTO THE BILL.
WE'LL START WITH EXPANDING
MEDICARE.
YOU SAW SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS
WITH THE CLIP AT THE BEGINNING
OF YOUR SHOW.
I HAD JUST ASKED HIM HE'D BEEN
TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND I ASKED
WHAT ASSURANCES HE GOT FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE SAID IT'S NOT THE PRESIDENT
THAT'S THE PROBLEM BUT PEOPLE
THE MINORITY IN THE SENATE
CONTINUING TO PUSH FOR THAT TO
EXPAND TO DENTAL, VISION AND
HEARING AND A MEDICAID EXPANSION
TO THE 12 STATES THAT HAVE NOT
DONE THAT.
I TALKED TO TAMMY BALDWIN TODAY
AND SHE TOLD US ABOUT A
COMPROMISE THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO INSTEAD OF STARTING A FEDERAL
MEDICAID PROGRAM FOR THE
EXPANSION, INSTEAD SUBSIDIZE
ESSENTIALLY PLANS THROUGH
OBAMACARE.
THEY'RE WORKING ON THAT TRYING
TO MAKE SURE SENATOR MANSION
WILL GET ON BOARD AS THEY SEEK
TO EXPAND MEDICAID AND ENSURE AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE AND YOU
HAVE PRESCRIPTION DRUG
NEGOTIATING COSTS FOR THAT.
WE KNOW KYRSTEN SINEMA AND
OTHERS WITH PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES IN THEIR HOME STATES
OR DISTRICTS HAVE REALLY PUSHED
BACK AND HAD RESISTANCE TO THAT.
THAT CONTINUES TO BE PAID OUT.
PAID LEAVE AS YOU MENTIONED AT
THE BEGINNING OF YOUR SHOW
APPEARS TO BE DROPPING OFF
ALTHOUGH I'LL TELL YOU ONCE THAT
NEWS BROKE LATE THIS EVENING
WHEN WE WERE HERE, THEY WERE
GOING THROUGH THE FINAL VOTE
SERIES AND THERE WERE VERY UPSET
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS AND ALSO ON
THE HOUSE SIDE AS WELL AT THE
IDEA THAT THIS COULD GET DROPPED
FROM THE PACKAGE.
SO SENATOR GILLIBRAND SAYING
THEY ARE PUSHING.
CLIMATE IS PROBABLY THE ONE,
DON, HAS A LOT OF OPTIMISM FROM
PEOPLE.
WE GOT A LETTER FROM NANCY
PELOSI AND SHE SENT IT TO HOUSE
DEMOCRATS TODAY.
SHE WAS VERY OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
THE CLIMATE PROPOSALS.
WE'RE HEARING IT COULD BE
UPWARDS OF $500 MILLION WILL BE
THE BIGGEST CHUNK OF MONEY IN
THE PACKAGE, LIKELY.
>> ARLET, I WANT TO BRING YOU
IN.
IT A BIG DEAL.
THIS IS A BIG TRIP FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND A BIG DEAL SINCE
WE'RE HEARING HE'S DELAYING THE
FOREIGN TRIP TO MEET WITH WHITE
HOUSE -- EXCUSE ME, TO MEET WITH
HOUSE DEMOCRATS TOMORROW
MORNING.
IS HE GOING TO BE TWISTING SOME
ARMS?
DOES HE EXPECT TO CLOSE A DEAL
BEFORE HE GOES?
>> WELL, DON, THE WHITE HOUSE
HAD LONG BEEN ENTERTAINING THE
POSSIBILITY OF HAVING PRESIDENT
BIDEN GO IN PERSON TO MAKE THIS
APPEAL TO HOUSE DEMOCRATS.
ULTIMATELY, THEY WANTED TO MAKE
SURE IT WOULD BE BENEFICIAL TO
THE PROCESS.
TOMORROW THE PRESIDENT WILL BE
HEADING UP TO CAPITOL HILL IN
THE MORNING TO MEET WITH HOUSE
DEMOCRATS.
A SOURCE I SPOKE WITH SAID HE'D
SPEAK TO THEM IN PERSON WHEN IT
COMES TO THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL AND THE
LARGER ECONOMIC PACKAGE BUT THE
PRESIDENT CERTAINLY WAS HOPING
TO HEAD INTO THIS FOREIGN TRIP
WITH SOME TYPE OF AGREEMENT ON
HIS TOP LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
ONE BIG QUESTION GOING FORWARD,
WE'VE HEARD THAT HOUSE
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS WOULD LIKE TO
SCHEDULE A VOTE ON THE
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE PRO
POSTAL BUT PROGRESSIVES ARE
STILL INSISTING THAT THEY WANT
TO SEE SOME ACTUAL LEGISLATIVE
TEXT THAT COULD BE VOTED ON AND
NOT JUST A FRAME WORK.
THEY WANT TO ACTUALLY SEE THE
TANGIBLES OF WHAT THIS PLAN IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
THE CONGRESSWOMAN JAYAPAL SAID
SIMPLY HAVING THE PRESIDENT COME
AND ASK FOR THEM TO VOTE FOR THE
BILL WASN'T NECESSARILY GOING TO
GET HER MEMBERS ON BOARD.
SO WE WILL SEE TOMORROW WHAT
KIND OF HEAVY LIFTS THE
PRESIDENT MIGHT HAVE AHEAD FOR
HIM AS HE IS MEETING WITH THOSE
HOUSE DEMOCRATS.
HE COULD BE POSTPONE -- THAT
MEETING SUPPOSED TO BE AROUND
9:00 A.M.
WE DON'T KNOW WHEN HE'LL LEAVE
FOR ROME BUT THE WHITE HOUSE
SAID HE CAN ONLY DELAY THE TRIP
A BIT STARTING ON FRIDAY.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS CERTAINLY
ACTING WITH A REAL SENSE OF
URGENCY TALKING TO THOSE TWO KEY
HOLDOUT SENATORS, MANSION AND
SINEMA AND TRYING TO TAKE IN
CONCERNS SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS
AND YOU SAW SENATOR SANDERS HERE
AT THE WHITE HOUSE A MEETING
WITH THE PRESIDENT FOR A LITTLE
OVER AN HOUR TODAY.
SO THE PRESIDENT IS REALLY
TRYING TO TAKE A HANDLE ON ALL
SIDES WITHIN HIS DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AS HE IS HOPING THEY CAN
COME TOGETHER AND PUSH HIS
ECONOMIC AGENDA ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING JESSICA MENTIONED,
THAT IS A PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
THE CORNER STONE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA.
HOW BIG OF A BLOW IS IT IF THIS
IS OUT OF THIS PLAN?
>> IT'S PRETTY BIG.
THIS IS A CENTRAL COMPONENT OF
WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAD BEEN
PROPOSING.
YOU'LL REMEMBER THEY TOUTED
THERE WOULD BE 12 WEEKS OF PAID
FAMILY LEAVE THAT WAS LATER
WHITTLED DOWN TO FOUR WEEKS AND
IT WAS A TOWN HALL LAST WEEK
WITH ANDERSON COOPER WHERE THE
PRESIDENT WAS TOUTING THIS AND
TALKING ABOUT HOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE REALLY -- THEY
SUPPORT THIS TYPE OF MEASURE AND
THEY WANT TO SEE THIS TYPE OF
ASSISTANCE.
NOW, WE ARE LEARNING THAT IT IS
LIKELY SCRAPS COMPLETELY FROM
THE PLAN A CONCESSION FROM JOE
MANSION THAT EXPRESSED
RESERVATIONS ABOUT INCLUDING
THAT IN THE PROPOSAL AND OTHER
ELEMENTS OF THE PLAN NOT MAKING
THE CUT ANYMORE.
WHEN IT COMES TO FREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, THE RAISING THE
CORPORATE TAX RATE.
IT WAS A FEW HOURS AGO THE WHITE
HOUSE WAS TOTING THE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE AS A HISTORIC INVESTMENT
IN THE PLAN.
OF COURSE, THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS THIS WHITE HOUSE WILL BE
TOTING IF THIS DEAL COMES
TOGETHER.
THERE IS SUCH AS FREE PRESCHOOL
AND OTHER INCENTIVES LIKE THE
ONE-YEAR EXTENSION OF THE CHILD
TAX CREDIT.